just that do I punch you Yoshi well that
would be kind of worthless because I
know a ton of fourteen-year-old girls
okay kick is it I know a ton of
fourteen-year-old girls what belt are
they look Dwight is a wuss when we
rented Armageddon no right at the end of
it Michael I told you that was because
it was New Year's Eve and it started to
snow at exactly midnight gonna leave
mother asteroid punch you
oh okay here we go come on oh did I want
to harm Michael the one man I've been
hired to protect no I did not are you
okay
alright thank you
I come from a long line of fighters my
maternal grandfather was the toughest
guy I ever knew world war ii veteran
killed 20 men then spent the rest of the
war in an allied prison camp my father
battled blood pressure and obesity all
his life different kind of fight I'm
going to the dentist okay I have to have
an emergency crown put in algea gasps
it's a new dentist
he's far I might be gone three hours
three hours Wow
have fun
I could save the branch really if you
let me run it okay okay I can run it
what would you do differently mostly get
rid of waste which is half the people
there and clean house right here it's
all for me okay wait you must feel
strongly to speak with me hey behind
Michaels back and turn on so many of
your coworkers
the decision to turn on Michael was
difficult but once I did it I didn't
look back and mostly I feel that Michael
would approve it's really what's best
for the branch and I could care less
about my co-workers so here we are it's
all on the table
I want the branch lead your decision
oh by the way there's a new and Taylor
outlet store near here I know you like
their earrings
I was just wondering since I'm probably
gonna have to stay late
could you ask Dwight to stay late too so
he can walk me to my car come in oh I
hate to break this to you but Dwight
can't stop you from being mugged he's
just not tough enough
he's a purple belt that's really high I
could beat up Dwight that's ridiculous I
can murder him
it's just that out there you was out
there saying all right first white now
watch let me take you from behind him
wait watch out Kelly my sucker puncher I
didn't sucker punch you Michael no
really in case you'd remember I was
defending my honor oh is that like a
samurai really well they offered Dwight
was for one punch which I absorbed I had
no idea that there would be a second
punch so catch-22 okay fine tit for tit
give it your best shot
two punches go look if we were in a bar
right now there would be two punches we
punching you and you hitting the floor
no I'd block your first pop yeah during
you in effect oh really
yeah you know what you're just lucky
that we're at work right now ooh what
about Dwight's dojo no big SAP quiet
it's free during the day it's fine look
hey Michael hey Toby hey you know what I
have an idea why don't you leave right
now why don't you walk away from the
room okay fine we'll go at lunch Michael
all right I've had a very interesting
conversation with one of your employees
oh that's nice no it wasn't
I just stole didn't you think you can
run the branch better than you what you
were at the dentist can't have people
undermining you get control of your
branch immediately okay Oh start
thinking that he could turn Jan against
me she's my ex-lover ish
Dwight can I talk to you for a second
wow this is tough mom what oh ah well I
just got off the phone with Jam and she
demoted me no yeah you know what the
craziest part of this is she demoted me
to your job and she said that you should
be expecting a call later from corporate
and that I guess that means that you
were going to be acting manager of
dunder-mifflin Scranton I can't believe
this news that Wow yeah I told her I
didn't know whether you'd want to do it
because you've always been so loyal to
me you've been my most trusted Ally you
said that yep I did I said
but I think you should do it oh gosh if
you think I should
then I will after a clean strike to the
chest stomach for kidneys I will
separate you and award a point first
person to three wins all right yes since
a lot of rules a lot of rules on the
street we didn't have any rules maybe
one no kicks to the groin home for
dinner okay
game on man leave the leg come an action
man okay Oh No hey it was my pants no
points for pants but you have no look no
you're something
[Music]
well I guess it's time that I turn over
the keys to the famous Sebring no thank
you
it's a corporate least white you earned
it no thanks
what not my style but you said you liked
it
you've always admired it and that was
before I'm thinking about getting
something German something with decent
gas mileage plus the convertible is a
ridiculous choice for this climate dig
it back No
that's my car
what does my car yes I know Dwight I
know I know I know know what Jan called
me about your little meeting no no what
you did this I've made the whole thing
up it's great this Hebrew school do you
dare you Dwight don't fire me please
give me one good reason why a year-long
different month a year I have the
laundry machine I don't know I can trust
you you can't you can't but I promise
I'll never return you again can I do
and you can hug it out [ __ ]
you